okay so today we're going to talk about
the difference between cod liver oil
versus fish oil I've been getting some
questions on this so I want to cover it
now with cod liver oil you're not going
to have as much omega-3 fatty acids
which is EPA in DHA so with fish oil
you're going to have higher amounts of
EPA and DHA so if we compare those with
cod liver oil you're dealing with like
8% EPA and with fish you're gonna get
18% so it's significantly more but not
like way over the top okay and then DHA
10% vs. 12% so these are pretty close
this is just a little bit more
I prefer cod liver oil because it has
high levels of vitamin A and vitamin D
and the perfect balance that you need
whereas fish oil does not okay now the
benefit of vitamin A for the eyes are
huge preventing night blindness helping
the macula of the eye it's good for skin
immune system and even can decrease the
risk of kidney stones however that the
studies on that were mainly done with
getting the vitamin A from beef liver
not cholera well different sources of
vitamin A give different benefits column
a well though really helps the the eyes
especially night blindness now vitamin D
can help you decrease blood pressure
decrease stress improve asthma skin
issues like eczema and psoriasis
autoimmune conditions so D is really
good for that and it will also improve
your overall mode now the benefit of
omega-3 and I'm talking about EPA and
DHA
are anti-inflammatory benefits brain
benefits heart immune nervous system and
the blood itself now there are other
omega-3 fatty acids in like walnuts for
example and flaxseed and other nuts but
here's the thing those are precursors
it's called ala even though it's an
omega-3 it's a precursor to the two the
more of the active form of omega-3 fatty
acids so if you think you're getting all
of your omega-3 from ala you
not because it has to be converted and
only a smaller percentage is converted
however you can get DHE from final
planked in other sources and lastly the
type of cod liver I'm going to recommend
is virgin cod liver oil it's less
processed it has does they don't add the
vitamins back in it comes naturally with
vitamin A and vitamin D and so it's just
it's a higher quality product alright
thanks for watching so if you're
enjoying this content go ahead and share
it with someone that could really
benefit from it